today on the matt wall show the media
will stop at nothing to distract from
the hunter biden scandal they somehow
managed to stoop to a whole new low this
week you wouldn't think it's possible
but they did also five headlines
including joe biden giving his fullest
answer yet
on the court packing question and it's
not a good answer and a deeply offensive
ranking of halloween candy that we have
to discuss
in our daily cancellation i'm going to
cancel everyone
once and for all all people all of us
and i have been given no choice i'll
explain why all that coming up but first
i can't emphasize enough the importance
of protecting yourself when you're
online
october is national cyber security
awareness month a collaborative effort
to make sure
every american has what they need to
stay safe and secure online
individuals and organizations are being
reminded if you connect it protect it
you know easy to remember
easy to do also um and uh we are all
encouraged to take proactive steps to
enhance cyber security and protect our
part
of cyberspace it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet
you could miss a lot of the different
threats that are out there by just
monitoring your credit so you got to do
more than that lifelock does a lot more
than that lifelock detects a wide range
of identity threats like your social
security number being for sale and dark
web
no one you know and they do much more
than that but no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions
at all businesses lifelock though can
see threats that you are probably going
to miss on your own join now and save up
to 25
off your first year go to lifeblock.com
walsh
that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off you know we on the right complain
about the media a lot
conservative commentators like me
especially complain about it
justifiably so they deserve all the
criticism and then some
but i'm afraid that the constant stream
of complaints prompted by a
constant stream of offenses worthy of
complaint have made us
so numb that we can't appreciate the
magnitude the severity
uh the perhaps historic significance of
the evil being perpetrated by the media
right now as we speak which isn't to say
they're behaving worse now than they've
ever
behaved before after all just in the
last few years we've seen them
do many things try to ruin a teenage
boy's life for wearing a maga hat and
smiling we've seen them orchestrate of
course a ruthless
smear campaign against a supreme court
nominee and not for the first time
in the last few months we've seen them
intentionally foment race riots
directly on the heels of them helping to
push
lockdowns that put millions of people
out of work and add that to the various
hoaxes they perpetrated
in order to um in order to try to take
down the trump administration it becomes
clear
why it's so hard to be shocked or
appropriately outraged by
what these people do anymore but let's
not allow that to overshadow
what has happened in the last several
days and i won't even spend much time
on the sideshow of the media coming out
of defense of jeffrey tubin
who of course masturbated in front of
co-workers during a zoom meeting
there have been multiple media
personalities and outlets who have
outright
defended tuba including this daily news
new york daily news article claiming
quote jeffrey toobin's history of bad
sexual judgment
is really about our unease with
masturbation
and he continues but i'm guessing you do
the same dear reader maybe you should
stop feeling weird and guilty about that
this is from jonathan zimmerman who is
telling on himself more than anything no
jonathan
i do not expose myself during zoom
meetings um i think most people don't
it's never happened on a zoom meeting
i've been a part of
thank god if you do you should indeed
feel guilty and weird about that
of course the problem here is that tuban
pulled out his tube
during during a work meeting he you know
he he didn't
he didn't think the camera was on but
even so
why are you doing that then during a
work meeting this is certainly worse
than anything louis ck ever did
louis ck at least according to the
stories
asked for consent before he engaged with
himself and he did it in private which
was more than could be said for tubin
yet tubin has media defenders louis c.k
had none why well
even though louis ck is a liberal tubin
is one of theirs he belongs to the media
and more importantly he's seen as an
important cog
in the machine to defeat trump as the
toronto star article directly argued
saying quote the country needs him
so we can't afford afford to worry about
him masturbating in front of co-workers
but this as i said is a sideshow for the
most part
more important than tuben's antics is
the bombshell scandal surrounding hunter
biden who has been getting up to
antics of his own antics that include
perhaps potentially money laundering fox
news reported yesterday reading now
from fox news website the fbi subpoena
of a laptop and hard drive reportedly
belonging to hunter biden
came in connection with a money law
during investigation in late 2019
according to
documents obtained by fox news and
verified by multiple federal law
enforcement officials who reviewed them
it is unclear at this point whether the
investigation is ongoing or if it was
directly related to hunter biden
multiple federal law enforcement
officials as well as two separate
government officials confirmed the
authenticity of these documents
which were signed by fbi special agent
joshua wilson wilson did not immediately
respond to fox news's request for
comment
um one of the documents obtained by fox
news
was apparently designated as a quote
receipt for property
from which details from the bureau's
interactions with john paul
mack isaac the owner of the mac shop who
reported the laptops contents to
authorities
and so that's that's the fox news report
there speaking of confirming
authenticity
hunter biden's business partner who is
by no means a republican operative
has now also come out and confirmed the
authenticity of the emails that were
first published
by the new york post for which the post
is still by the way locked out of its
twitter account last i checked
but he's come out and confirmed it again
reading from foxes says
tony bobulinsky who was
listed as the recipient of an email
published by the new york post that
appeared to detail a business
arrangement involving a chinese company
and the members of the biden family
has confirmed that the email is genuine
provided more information regarding the
biden's role in the deal
the email includes a note that hunter
has some office expectations he will
elaborate
proposed equity split references 20 for
quote
h and quote 10 held by
h for the big guy with no further
details
the reference to the big guy in the much
publicized email
is in fact a reference to joe biden this
is what bob youninsky said in a
statement to fox news
bobby litzki said it is uh said he is
the ceo of
sinnohack holdings which he explained
quote was a partnership between the
chinese operating
um through cefc chairman yay and the
biden family he said he was brought on
as
ceo by hunter biden um who was listed as
uh
and james gilliar who was listed as
sender of the email bob bielinski went
on to say
he does not believe joe biden's past
claim that he and hunter
did not discuss his son hunter's
businesses claiming that hunter
frequently
referenced asking him for his sign off
or advice on various potential deals
so there's no way to get around this the
emails are real it's it's been confirmed
by one of the guys involved in the email
exchange what else do you need
and that would be proof enough but it's
not even the only proof the fact that
the fbi is investigating the laptops is
also evidence that the laptops well
exist at least
yet the media has been involved in a
wide-ranging concerted
choreographed effort to blatantly lie
about this story cover it up
with a big help from big helping hand
from big tech
and then yesterday finding new lows to
sync to somehow
many media outlets all at once try tried
to discredit rudy giuliani
who's the man of course who obtained the
laptops started running with a story
that the new borat film which comes out
tomorrow catches him
in a hotel room with a quote underage
girl touching his genitals
that's what the media reported sounds
pretty bad until you realize that it's a
total fabrication
as rudy himself said but don't take it
from rudy ben dreyfus
editorial director mother jones not at
all a conservative publication put it
mildly
looked at the segment in the film and
said that the reporting is false
straight up it's wrong he says quote
i've now seen the scene with rudy
giuliani and though it is creepy for
other reasons it is being described on
twitter in a false way
he does not have his hand down his pants
in a sexual way he is tucking his shirt
back
in after she untucks it removing his mic
the scene is confusingly edited for
comedic purposes which makes sense since
this is a comedy film and not a 60
minutes expose
it would be good to keep that in mind in
light of the flat the um
flattening of media where everything can
seem like everything else now this all
stems from a bit if you can call it a
bit where
an actress pretends to be a reporter rev
uh interviewing rudy in a hotel room
at the end of the interview she suggests
going back to her room for a drink
she flirts with him he tucks in his
shirt
then that image is taken used out of
context but the thing is
even if he was flirting back to her who
cares
the actress is 24. it's not an underage
girl she she was initiating she's 24.
rudy isn't even married so
how would this be a scandal how would
this be remotely a scandal
even if he was doing what they claimed
he was doing apparently he wasn't but it
wouldn't matter if he did
this was an attempt by sasha baron cohen
to simply destroy rudy giuliani in the
name of comedy comedy with scare quotes
that's of course how sasha baron cohen's
comedies work now he tries and have
really always worked he tries to
embarrass and humiliate people for his
own entertainment
often people who unlike rudy are not
wealthy or prominent
so sasha baron cohen is a rich hollywood
dirtbag
who goes around trying to embarrass
mostly poor people and middle class
people for fun
once in a while throwing in a prominent
republican and then just straight up
smearing them
i mean you get what the what the attempt
was in this bit it was just to
it's just to flat out destroy rudy
giuliani that's what they wanted to do
even if you don't like rudy giuliani
it's not that's not comedy that's that's
a that's an attempted hit job
and it didn't work and it never made
sense anyway given again this is a
grown adult woman uh apparently flirting
with another grown adult man
man neither of them are even married
where's the scandal here but
this was all of course an attempt to
distract um
from the hunter biden scandal and the
media will
stop at nothing absolutely nothing
this is what happens when they when they
say that that
donald trump is as bad as hitler and
that his supporters are nazis and white
supremacists and racists
they mean it they really believe it
and you add that to the fact that these
are moral relativists who believe that
the ends justify the means already
well when the end you have in mind is
getting rid of hitler
anything goes there are there are no
moral qualms
no ethical standards do anything
and that's what we're seeing happen
right now
and it's gonna get worse we can
guarantee that over the next few days
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know as we talk about the craziness
in the media and in the world generally
um and all these companies and various
outlets that you can't trust that's why
it just it just again highlights and
emphasizes the need to have
some companies out there who share your
your values and who are working on your
side
in the culture and when you find a
company like that you got to support
them
and that's really easy to do fortunately
with charity mobile the pro-life phone
company
look five percent of your monthly plan
your of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
and on top of that so that's um that's
the the
the good deed that you're helping
charity mobile do
also though it's a great service new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping
there are no contracts or no termination
fees there's no no strings attached you
get with a lot of
cell phone companies and there's no risk
um at all with the 30 day guarantee
plus on top of that if you have any
issues live customer service based right
here in the usa
uh and a lot of other things do you get
free usage alerts you get you have the
ability to block
uh use of cellular data picture messages
text messages
on any uh or all lines on your account
so this is a good way if you have
kids and they have a phone you know good
way to protect them as well
um but most of all you're helping to
build a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life
company and like i said it's it's a it's
a win-win when you've got a good company
and a good cause and it's also up
up to us to support those companies when
we find them and here's one right here
call
charity mobile at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
also our dimension uh by the way you
know as we've been talking about this
hunter biden laptop story that was
buried by facebook and twitter
and a big tech teaming up with uh big
media to cover this up
now personally as i've said i'm
i'm worried that the hunter biden stuff
will not
um have the effect that it should
it won't resonate with the voters i
don't know but i i have a
cynical view as i do most things with
this but big tech's attempts to censor
the story
i think that is something especially
that resonates with with voters because
voters are worried
about censorship and for good reason um
and you know i think there's a role for
the government to step in here but
you also have to balance that with
having them involved in the dangers of
getting
government involved in anything and so
there's a lot to balance and think about
that's why this week our own
ceo uh co-ceo jeremy boring launched a
new podcast titled enough
in his first episode released yesterday
jeremy takes on the leftist outlets
trying to get conservatives kicked off
of facebook this has been an effort
obviously that they've been engaged in
for a long time
listen now at the lincoln in the
description and subscribe to jeremy's
podcast to get his other
his other rants about big government big
tech hollywood hypocrisy
anything else that comes to mind it's a
great podcast check it out and if you
like it
leave a review so it gets recommended
to more people all right we'll get to
our headlines here
um as you can see by the way boxes this
is my last this is our last stay in this
in this house and so that's why
everything is empty and very sad
um more about that later though number
one a clip from joe biden
that he posted which is getting some
attention well
i'll just play it for you first watch
this america was an idea
an idea we hold these truths to be
self-evident
we've never lived up to it but we've
never walked away from it before
and i just think we have to be more
honest and let our kids know
as we raise them what actually did
happen
acknowledge our mistakes so we don't
repeat them
okay joe first of all no america is not
an idea it's a country it's a country
founded on
founded on certain ideas but it's not
itself an idea
uh this is not a pedantic
point here this is important the left
actually does want us to see america
as an idea and not a country because
that's how they
justify rampant unchecked immigration
that's that's that's how they do it
that's their line they say that
essentially as long as someone has the
same idea
then they're already american they're
already part of the country it's just an
idea
but no america is a legal entity it is a
country
and you know one of the ways i know that
is that because um i have to pay taxes
and so do you probably
you don't have to pay taxes to an idea
you pay taxes to a country
and i'm guessing that on tax day i can't
refuse to pay my taxes on the grounds
that
ideas don't cause money when the irs
comes knocking on my door
wondering why i haven't paid taxes i
can't like
rip a bong hit and say hey man
america's an idea bro okay it's just
like
an idea chill out man i something tells
me that that
that line of reasoning that argument
will not be persuasive to the irs agents
but
i don't know number two from the daily
wire says cnn host chris cuomo was
shamed by his building manager and
threatened with a fine for disobeying
regulations and walking through the
building maskless
fox news host tucker carlson released a
letter that cuomo's building manager
apparently sent
to the cnn personality on august 6th
outlining
the complaints against him and uh i'll
play this this is tucker reading the
letter
listen this show has obtained a letter
from the management of chris cuomo's new
york city apartment building
the letter in question is addressed
directly to chris cuomo the date on it
is august 6th
2020. here's what it says quote dear mr
cuomo as i'm sure you know
because of the ongoing covid19 health
crisis on april 15
2020 governor cuomo issued executive
order 202.17
which requires anyone over the age of
two to wear a face mask or cloth that
covers their
mouth and nose while in a public space
okay that's how it starts
as a fair guess that chris cuomo already
knew that because
after all he's the mask guy and of
course his own brother
issued the order so with that in mind
listen to how the letter
continues quote you have been observed
entering
and exiting the building and riding the
elevator without the required face
coverings
even though staff members have asked you
to comply with this requirement
you have refused to do so this is a
violation of the executive order
building policy and it places other
residents and our staff
at risk there are no exceptions to this
rule and you are required to comply
the letter goes on to threaten chris
cuomo with a 500
fine if he continues to endanger his
neighbors and the city with his
masklessness
that's what the letter says yeah no
surprise there although i have to say i
do enjoy
tucker carlson casually destroying
chris cuomo on his show like twice a
week now it i i do enjoy it um
it's someone has to do it and with the
mask thing of course
as we've seen time and time again pure
hypocrisy
not just the mask thing but lock downs
everything
these people that are pushing it they
don't believe it themselves
they don't think that that it applies to
them and it's really easy to support
something like a masked mandate a
lockdown when you
personally are exempt even if you're not
really exempt but if you feel like
you're exempt and you're gonna operate
that way then it's pretty easy to
advocate it for everybody else so more
of the same there number three
back to joe biden um finally giving his
i guess you could say his fullest answer
yet
on the question of court packing it's
still not really an answer but it's the
most we've gotten from him here's what
he says
if elected what i will do is i'll put
together a national commission of
bipartisan commission of scholars
constitutional scholars
democrats republicans liberal
conservatives
and i will ask them to over a
180 days come back to me with
recommendations as to how
to reform the court system because it's
getting out of whack
the way in which it's being handled and
it's not about court packing there's a
number of other things that our
constitutional scholars have debated and
i'd look to see what
recommendations that commission might
make so you're telling us you're going
to
study this issue about whether to pack
the court no
whether there's a number of alternatives
that are go well beyond packing
this is a live ball oh it is a live ball
no it is a live ball we're going to have
to do that
and you're going to find there's a lot
of conservative constitutional scholars
who are saying it as well
the last thing we need to do is turn the
supreme court into just a political
football whoever has the most votes gets
whatever they want
presidents come and go supreme court
justices stay for generations
it's getting out of whack he says it's
all out of whack
the courts are to be clear here um
when he says it's out of whack what he
means is that
republicans were able to confirm a few
justices
that's that's what out of whack is the
left's stranglehold on the court was
broken
and so that means the court is broken
that's what out of whack means
that's what they mean that's what the
left always means when they say
something is is out of whack broken
needs to be reformed desperate reform is
needed we need to change it
fundamentally fundamental change what
they mean is that in this particular
area things have not gone 100
our way uh
and and so that's that's always what
they mean we need to reform it because
things have not worked out 100 how we
want them to
the whole thing is broken if this isn't
working exactly how i wanted to then it
must be broken
that's it's the only explanation i can
come up with
number four the speaking of it not going
how they want the senate judiciary
committee today voted
12-0 to advance amy coney barrett's
nomination sending it to the senate vote
uh
i think they're a vote on monday so to
the full senate
the reason it was 12-0 is that all the
democrats boycotted the vote
poor guys they're very upset their
tummies hurt and they just weren't going
to show up
to vote i don't i don't know what so now
it's a unanimous
now it's a unanimous decision to move
her uh nomination forward
that's how they what are they even
trying to achieve here politically and
in terms of optics
you're upset you can't really say why
you're upset
well you don't like her because of her
what you perceive her ideology to be
but all this stuff that they tried about
how this is unprecedented this is
unconstitutional
of course that's ridiculous so they
couldn't come up with any good reason to
boycott but they did
politically though all you have done is
ensure that
now we can say she was unanimously
approved
by the senate judiciary committee good
job guys
number five finally the uh the website
538 has published what they call the
ultimate definitive
halloween candy power ranking i don't
know what method they used
to arrive at this but it is a it is a
fatally flawed method i can tell you
that this is what their top ten okay
here's
here's their top ten reese's peanut
butter cup
reese's miniatures twix kitkats snickers
reese's pieces
milky way reese's stuffed with pieces
reese's stuffed with pieces
um peanut butter m ms and butterfinger
payday candy bars come don't don't come
don't make the list until
number 47. they put milk duds ahead of
paydays
and they've got nerds above mike and i
speaking of speaking of out of whack
this list is out of whack it's absurd
it's offensive
reese's are way way way overrepresented
they're they they make up like half of
the top ten if not more
which of course is to be expected for
the most overrated thing on earth
potentially
if i were to make a list my own list of
the most overrated things
period in all categories of existence
it would probably be number one reese's
number two
dogs number three the beatles number
four the beach
number five star wars those are the most
overrated things but reese's is
definitely at the top of that list
peanut butter itself is overrated
but reese's peanut butter isn't even
real peanut butter it's like some kind
of factory byproduct
with a vaguely peanuty flavor surrounded
by stale chocolate
snickers obviously is the best candy
just objectively and scientifically
speaking
paydays should be in the top five
and if you've got a more mature adult
palette able to pick up on the
subtleties of flavor
uh then you're gonna you're gonna enjoy
payday mike and ike's are top five milky
way
probably rounds out the top five kitkats
are great
if you like the taste of cardboard
butterfingers are very good if you're
the sort of person who
enjoys eating congealed hardened vomit
um but it doesn't belong anywhere in the
top
100 or anywhere else on earth frankly so
this list is an abomination
as expected or we get to our daily
cancellation and it's an important one
in just a second but first um you know
it's it's really important when you're
making investments
to hedge your investments with some gold
but it can also be really expensive
to just go out and buy gold so here's
something new
you know how the price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately now there's a new
way to buy gold through a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as 30
a month you pay each month and once your
gold stash reaches
the price of their gold bars they
discreetly ship acre gold to your house
so this is a great service it's a new
way of doing it um
and it makes it seem obtainable whereas
before it could seem like it wasn't acre
lets you invest in physical gold without
coming out of pocket all at once acre
keeps you updated
on your gold stash every month and it
ships once you reach the price threshold
with acre
taking physical delivery your gold means
it's safe and sound
and it's in your hands and you don't
have to worry about it acre ships your
gold directly and discreetly to your
door
and acre just recently introduced their
new 100 per month subscription
for their 5 gram gold bar you want you
want to check this out and use this i
i know for me i have my my
my vision for our new home and we have a
new home in nashville
and i don't know if i'll be able this
might not be achievable but of course
like any kid i grew up
wanting like scrooge mcduck to have a
whole room full of gold coins i could
dive into so maybe i can achieve that
dream here
visit getacregold.com walsh and start
investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acres giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention
at get underscore acre again that's
get acre gold dot com slash walsh uh and
uh a big thank you to aker gold for
supporting the show
we're excited about this new sponsor uh
another
show coming up today as with everything
in 2020 there's been a lot of drama
about the presidential debates
but we're ready for the next and final
debate which is happening tonight so
join us at 8 45 pm eastern 5 40 p.m
pacific
for an all new episode of daily wire
backstage to watch the debate with us
get our immediate live reactions uh and
even better you could join daily wire
now as an insider or all-access member
and get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all debate coverage live on our apple tv
or roku app
members of course get all the perks we
always tell you about and they're great
you know
all of our live broadcasts the show
library three hours of bench shapiro
show every day
exclusive readers pass content and if
you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join our
all-access live
every day with one of your hosts where
we have a kind of casual conversation
that's a lot of fun so
watch the debate with us on
dailywire.com on youtube on facebook and
get it many places and get 20 off your
daily wire membership with code debate
when you sign up today okay time for our
daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
all canceled everyone
everyone's canceled we're all canceled
enough is enough the
reason we're canceled is because a nasa
spacecraft just yesterday
landed on an asteroid 200 million miles
away
it landed touchdown collected samples to
bring back to earth
uh the the spacecraft left our planet
four years ago has traversed that great
distance actually has been
orbiting the asteroid for the last two
years and now we'll return home
with the mission completed now
understand that this rock
about the size of the empire state
building is traveling 60 000 miles an
hour
just think about that nasa sent a
spaceship 200 million miles away that's
over four times the average
or rather the minimum distance between
earth and mars they sent it
200 million miles to an object only the
size of a building
landed it in an area the size of three
parking spaces
touching down only three feet from the
precise targeted location
that is an utterly amazing engineering
feat it's mind-boggling it's spectacular
there's even a short video uh footage of
the event
why does all this mean that we're
canceled well because instead of talking
about that
about that tremendous and fascinating
subject
we've all been talking about jeffrey
tubin's penis
and borat and god knows what else this
is how it always goes we live in a
universe of wonders we're surrounded by
by by the astonishing the bewildering
the incredible
and none of that can hold our attention
or attract our interest
the way a story about a man publicly
masturbating can or the way that any
gossipy nonsense can or any pointless
controversy
we all complain about this though i hear
from people all the time oh i wish the
news would focus on positive
interesting things more people
complained to me about it about my show
matt i agree with you but i wish you'd
talk about positive things
no you don't no you don't you say you do
but you don't
we all say we do but none of us really
do the fact is
the positive the interesting the
non-controversial
these stories are out there that content
is out there
it just doesn't attract much attention
unless it's a story about like
a dog helping a blind man find his
favorite hat
and there's a cute two and a half minute
video we can share on facebook
that story you know is positive and the
video would get 15 billion views
but positive and significant positive
and consequential
positive and truly interesting those are
the stories that
almost nobody really cares about except
in theory
and if i were to spend a week talking
only about those kinds of positive
stories by the end of that week
i'd have maybe five listeners left my
audience would literally be cut in half
so we're all complicit we prefer the
inane the empty
over the wondrous and the enthralling
another example last year
there was a picture of a black hole
released first time ever that a black
hole has been photographed
you can see it here now that is an
object
55 million light years away 55
million light years a light year 6
trillion miles 55 million times 6
trillion you do the math i certainly can
and this thing is 6 billion times the
mass of the the sun
the word gargantuan doesn't begin to
describe it a force of power
beyond anything we can imagine anything
we've seen across distances
too vast and too empty to be
comprehended this picture was released
and you know what most people said it's
blurry
it's blurry it's boring i'm bored let's
see what kanye west is tweeting about
but i suppose that's better that
reaction is preferable to when five or
six years ago
a module was landed on a comet 300
million miles away
and the discussion around that event if
you remember remember centered around
the allegedly sexist shirt
of the scientist who headed up the
project
at least nobody found a reason to be
offended by the asteroid landing
yesterday or the black hole
but i'm sure our best minds are figuring
out a way to make that happen
now i really believe i really do that
aliens could land on this earth emerge
from their spaceships and start
revealing the secrets of the universe
and it wouldn't even trend on twitter or
make headlines on cnn
unless the aliens said something
homophobic or racist
or if they mention that they support
donald trump then in that case sure
global news cnn's headline would say
something like
aliens invade earth stir controversy
with offensive comments
then there'd be the buzzfeed article
replete with gifts and snarky one-liners
with a title like 10 most problematic
things the aliens said when they came to
earth
the aliens would look around shake their
heads and say holy [ __ ] you people are
stupid
and then leave they were going to tell
us how to cure all known diseases
harness energy directly from the core of
the sun but never mind
and after they leave within 12 hours the
new cycle will have moved on
three months later someone will somebody
will post a massively viral tweet
that says lol remember the time aliens
came
and there'd be like a gif from
spaceballs or mars attacks
and that will be the only record of the
event humanity's
last word on the subject so we're all
canceled
we're canceled for being us for being
human it's our greatest flaw
and on that appropriately dour note and
depressing note
i will end the show for today the last
show from my home here which is also
cancelled
this studio in fact my first studio that
which would of course be my car
was hauled away to the junkyard just
this morning and now this
so this is a time of change
of endings and new beginnings
so that's gonna do it for me have a
great day
farewell godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton
[Music]